mission réussie pour le Joseph Schult le
premier cargo au départ de l'Ukraine
après la fin de l'accord sur les
céréales est arrivé ce matin en Turquie
un défi lancé à la Russie qui menace
d'attaquer ce type de navire depuis
qu'elle a mis fin en juillet à l'accord
par lequel l'Ukraine pouvait exporter
ses céréales le navire a utilisé un
nouveau couloir humanitaire établi par
Kiev l'Ukraine utilise désormais le
Danube pour exporter ses céréales une
grande partie du trafic descend le long
du fleuve et finit par atteindre la mer
Noire à la frontière entre l'Ukraine et
la Roumanie
depuis plusieurs jours Moscou intensifie
ses attaques contre les infrastructures
portuaires ukrainiennes de la mer Noire
les pores et les silos à grains le long
du Danube ont notamment été bombardé par
des drones russes dans ce contexte la
communauté internationale cherche à
trouver un moyen de sécuriser le
transport des céréales vers le reste du
monde la Turquie quant à elle continue
de se poser en médiateur recepai perdoan
qui avait accueilli deux premières
séries de pour parler de paix avec
l'Ukraine espère rencontrer son
homologue russe Vladimir Poutine ce
mois-ci la reprise de la Corse sur
l'exportation des céréales ukrainiennes
devrait être à l'ordre du jour de leur
discussion